things developing in Brussels about the
proposed deal and summit with the UK
let's go back to our Europe
correspondent marks they ignite good
morning yes so we were speaking a few
minutes ago talking about the fact that
a new version of the political
declaration that is the future
relationship was being worked on well
here it is it's leaking like a sieve
here in Brussels and we have a copy of
it here what is interesting is it is now
26 pages long this was the original
document that was published last week
the first version of the political
declaration for the future relationship
to give it its proper name that was just
seven pages long we've been saying all
week that the the desire by by both
sides frankly but really in mrs. Mays
interest was to flesh out the detail in
this seven page document and turn it
into something much much more detailed
which would make it less likely that the
unpalatable stuff in the longer
withdrawal divorce deal things like the
Irish backstop the all UK Customs Union
less likely that those would come into
force and I'll admit I haven't read it
all yet we are going through it at the
moment but the the suggestion presumably
will be that this document is because
it's now 30 26 pages long it has in it
much much more detail about what that
future relationship and will look like
Donald Tusk is the president of the
European Council he has now sent this
document so to the capitals of the 27
remaining members of the EU the way it
works is that the Commission the
negotiators on both sides on the British
side and on the EU side have been
working on this document and I know that
they were still working on it last night
and that they worked through the night
since mrs. Mays meeting yesterday so
they worked on this document through the
night they have now published it the
commission has handed it to Donald Tusk
at the over at the council he has
distributed it to the 27 remaining
members of the EU they will now look at
it but he says that the Commission
president
inform me that it has been agreed at
negotiator level and agreed in principle
at political level subject to the
endorsement of leaders so unless there
are yet more flies in the ointment from
the likes of Spain or France then this
is it this is the document along with
the fat five eight five page document
that will be signed off by leaders on
Sunday I should say to that it looks as
though there's been no changes at all to
the long document which is what we
expected that they wouldn't want to
reopen that they've just put more
details into this document